while Megha Markos dream came true when
she became a duck just making seven out
for her first solo engagement and adding
a new twist to all the pregnancy
speculations the Duchess exited her car
wearing a sleek black long sleeve to
dress with her signature stilettos
tonight's look was form-fitting with a
belt around her middle the outfit is a
departure from the flowy top she wore
yesterday so how is Megan handling all
the rumors of possibly being pregnant
well I was there this evening if she's
at all worried about these pregnancy
rumors she doesn't seem to be showing it
and there was no hint of a baby bump she
looked sleek she looked elegant she
actually acknowledged the press pack
that were waiting just outside the Royal
Academy in central London and at one
point even gave a wave to the cameras
very confident and very happy with life
her II did not accompany his wife at the
opening of Oceana an exhibition of art
from Australia New Zealand and the
Pacific Islands they're the same
countries Megan will visit with Harry
next month it's an opportunity for them
to show themselves as team Sussex we
know the focus is going to very much be
on youth leadership on environmental
issues and of course on the Invictus
games
[Music]
[Applause]